there's a lot of couples that are coming
out of SNL there's something in the
water
I am NOT Lawrence economist why because
I ain't wanted a couple it's kind of
ruling this whole Emmys show right we're
doing our best you may see 80 and I'm
popping throughout the show touch your
neighbor Oh what did I do
I really like sort of the SNL takeover
of Emmys I was sure is weird if I
weren't here the show is executive
produced by SNL creator Lorne Michaels
and included appearances by thirteen
past and present cast members has there
ever been a tie at the end yeah you're
wearing one thank you good night the
critic reviews for co-host Colin Jost
and Michael che
where life luster at best but that
didn't stop SNL from taking home the
emmy for outstanding variety sketch
series Saturday Night Live Ben Affleck's
acts SNL producer Lindsay shippers make
her first public appearance since he
checked into rehab notably absent cast
member Pete Davidson and his fiancee
Ariana Grande her rep tells et they
decided to stay home in New York so she
could quote heal and mend after the
sudden death of her ex Mac Miller as no
alum bill heater took home the Emmy for
Outstanding Lead Actor in a Comedy
Series for his HBO series Barrie
backstage he crashed our interview with
his co-star and fellow winner Henry
Winkler this is my boss
Bill Hader hi Henry we have to work on
Wednesday you know that right I do and
I'm so excited we have at 7:00 a.m.
did you win an Emmy yes we both OH
[Music]